[Music]
now Tony Awards were last night yeah
yeah just a second hey Tony
everyone this is one of our cameramen
Tony how you doing
yeah Conan
how do you know about the Tony Awards
Tony are you serious yeah how do you
know about that little thing my wife and
I do every Sunday night Tony I was
talking about the big show where they
give awards to Broadway musicals oh
right right right okay never mind no no
wait what
tell us about your Tony Awards oh well
right well since you asked every
Saturday morning
my wife Brenda puts together a list of
stuff I got to do around the house right
right like a honey-do list yeah yeah but
she calls it her do it honey
list anyway the more stuff on the list
that I get done but bigger my award okay
all right we we get the idea yeah for
example let's say I change a lightbulb
maybe I'll get a little peck on the
cheek yeah okay right yep got it oh but
if I do something big like regrouting
entire bathroom oh boy
then it's time you know all right Tony
time full hey Tony we get the picture we
get it sex yes
[Applause]
congratulations Tony fellas that was
fantastic where's our Tony right
[Applause]
you